I know everyone's all bummed out about
Aaron Rodgers would they pay him like
what was the number 75 million million
yeah for two years and then he got
injured after four you know four plays
Howard that's guaranteed money I like to
see players be paid well and and
certainly if you're going to go out
there and get you know mutilated in the
NFL someone ought to get paid a lot of
the uh lower rung players they get
injured and then they're out they don't
even get paid that much money you take a
masterful athlete like Aaron Rodgers and
of course he's gonna get injured I mean
it shouldn't shock anyone there's a
guy's holding a ball from out of nowhere
somebody knocks him down and these guys
weigh over almost 300 pounds some of
them and they come in at some of the
fastest speeds it's like getting hit by
a car I came at him from behind he
didn't even see him right you know they
think it's an Achilles uh problem which
would be the end of the season for him
the sport is basically take a guy and
have him dance in the middle of the
freeway and hope he doesn't get hit by a
car other guys and try to throw a ball
at the same time
and if you think I'm being a douche or a
the average NFL career is 3.3
years how could a master athlete even
depend on it well the bills obviously
said let's ruin their great time
let's tee off on Aaron Rodgers let's not
even let him play a years ago since he
played in the NFL hey Jack how do you
say your last name Jack Newhart but yeah
I played for four years in the NFL had a
bunch of knee surgeries got pretty well
mangled uh you know Torah triceps tend
and all sorts of ankle sprains and
things like that so play just above the
average but man it is a uh it's a
violent Sport and I will say the league
does take there are programs in place
they do take a little bit better care of
you than sometimes advertise but it is
violent yeah well the point I'm making
is most people assume if a guy played in
the NFL he's a millionaire and I got
buddies who actually have played in the
NFL and they ain't millionaires they're
out working uh real hard they're doing
regular jobs I mean yeah I'm sitting in
a parking garage right now ready to go
into a meeting and and start selling
title insurance so I it you know right
what
it gets deposited in your bank account
is much different I think you know
people see those those advertised
figures and it's just it's not the case
you know a lot of guys most guys we got
to go out afterwards and pick up the
pieces and figure out who you are after
the game you know obviously you get to
live a dream and it's awesome but
there's life after you turn the page and
you know when you get beat up like that
it's uh and it gets taken away it is a
strange feeling when you first leave the
NFL and you're used to that kind of like
you know hey they take such good care of
you and you're a superstar you know what
I mean you're part of a big team
then all of a sudden you got to go to a
regular job are you at first like really
super angry it does create I think a
level of bitterness yeah it did take a
while for me to kind of swallow the fact
that the game was done with me and it
didn't quite end on my terms so it is
difficult and that bitterness is there
it subsides after time but it is
certainly still uh arrears its head
every once in a while you know I'll be
getting motherfucked by a customer or
something and it's just like you want it
you want to say man do you know what I
used to do for a living but it just it
doesn't matter anymore it kills you
sometimes and eats at you and that's
that's a bad event you gotta fight but
it's tough so I mean I I wouldn't change
anything yeah Jack I feel the pain
believe me man I get it all right I love
you Howard Love You Fred love you love
you too later Jack love you guys bye
foreign